it's a small comfort that we're not
alone in our fear of the dark or even of
our own shadows wherever we go a small
bit of darkness follows us whether it's
a natural effect of light or something
more sinister remains uncertain
this October on Friday the 13th from an
executive producer of The Walking Dead
and an executive producer of the x-files
from six terrifying tales based on the
podcast phenomenon lore until then we
offer you this short film inspired by
the series the worlds of shadow and
light can be very frightening for
children I'm dr. Michelle Garland and
I'm a clinical psychologist we all have
a shadow we have dark parts we have
aggression we have impulses that can
hurt people Carl Jung referred to the
shadow as the darker parts of ourselves
the part we keep safely hidden by our
conscious mind but for some the shadow
is an altogether real embodiment of evil
one that goes by many names I think when
we talk about shadow and shadow people
we're inherently talking about
psychology and our soul a spiritual
sense that there is something beyond the
physical
an obsession with the Shadow Realm is
what fueled the depraved desires of 15th
century noblemen shield array who
learned little children to an
unthinkable doom behind the walls of his
castle and the French countryside an
avowed fan of de Rais perverted
handiwork Edouard pay now the Beast of
Jersey terrorized the Isle of Wight from
the early 1960s
until his capture in 1971 donning a
rubber mask pain L broke into homes to
attack 13 women and children as they
like innocently sleeping it is the
echoes of haunting stories like these
that inspired the deadly myth of the
slender man a tall figure who is set to
reach through computers to beckon his
victims out of the safety of their homes
and into the darkness of the woods
it's a vanishing story and who hasn't
wanted to vanish but then also how scary
if you're taken his choice of attire as
appropriately the dark suit and tie
favored by Undertaker's though unlike
his contemporaries to look into his face
is to stare into a pale featureless void
that drives survivors to the brink of
insanity but can these shadow people
really be the physical embodiment of
evil from the world beyond or are they
just a story we tell ourselves to cope
with the darkness that lives within us
all we develop shadows from the time
were born and it's a defense system the
shadow people are the embodiment of
these defenses that we have
our innermost fears and twisted
curiosity as it seems will arrive at one
of two conclusions we are the leery prey
of the shadows or we stalk the prey with
them
[Applause]
[Music]